welcome to the third season of folding
ideas I know it's been a long time
coming but it's all Dan's fault I don't
feel so good oh quit your whingeing oh
my heart hurts I think I'm dying
please don't who will let it certainly
we can't let Annabelle do it again she's
a terrible editor the whole on without
me
prologue who what why I want to talk
about the Earthsea cycle by Ursula K Le
Guin a collection of five books and
various short stories and the sci-fi
original miniseries released by hallmark
in 2004 in broad terms we're going to be
discussing adaptations sickness the
various maladies and problems that
afflict films adapted from books because
books are an extremely popular source of
material for film there are literally
thousands of examples that I could draw
on for this hell I could easily
rededicate the show purely to book to
film comparisons and probably never run
out of material to cover so why the
Earthsea cycle and not say the Lord of
the Rings or Jurassic Park or The Hunger
Games or any of the many many others
well many of the points that I want to
make of movies doing a good job at
adapting you're probably already
familiar with I'll reference these films
to illustrate points but I don't really
need to spend much time explaining since
a lot of it is self-evident if you're
familiar with the films plus the sci-fi
miniseries is just terrible from start
to finish so we can have some fun
mocking it like seriously this one is
complete crap another reason that I'll
confess to is that I'm personally a big
fan of these books and while they're
certainly not unheard of compared to
Tolkien they're relatively unknown
without a lot of mainstream traction so
promoting them is sort of my way of
saying thanks to Ursula again for the
amazing work she's done the books are
written for young adults so they're not
particularly long or difficult but they
address some challenging issues and are
an absolute masterpiece of
world-building even though I'll be
spoiling some plot elements I will in no
way be able to cover everything
replaced the experience of reading them
for yourself so just go read them
chapter 1 books are awesome books are
awesome a lot of people talk about the
death of books as a medium but I don't
think books are ever going to go away
they're just too great a big advantage
of books is that they let you tell any
kind of story in any kind of setting
with few if any overarching financial
limitations Tolkien wrote several
fictional historical cyclopædia is about
the struggle of the agrarian hobbits in
an increasingly industrialized world and
the victory of the hobbit nation in
securing their own ethnic sovereignty
against the Yugoslavs in the aftermath
of World War one I mean damn it
Saruman in the war of the RAM the point
is that in a book you take two
characters who are talking to each other
and the cost of production remains the
same if they're talking in a white box a
cafe Times Square the moon the slopes of
Mount Doom or attack ships high over
Khorasan
the cost of printing a page is the same
you're relevant of what's happening on
that page this is what makes some
unadaptable books unadaptable you've
probably heard that phrase before Cloud
Atlas is unadaptable
Life of Pi is unadaptable Midnight's
Children is unadaptable what that phrase
usually means is that the story
translated into film isn't marketable
enough to justify the budget it would
require it's not that no one could ever
figure out how to put the book onto
screen it's just that it cost a billion
dollars and only like 50 people would go
see it books that get called unadaptable
tend to be intensely personal spiritual
journey type story set in sweeping
historical or fantastic settings
basically small stories set in really
expensive locations books also benefit
from having few set standards technical
or otherwise there are generalities but
books aimed at 13 year olds range from
150 to 700 pages which in movie terms is
like having your average summer
blockbuster range from one to five hours
as a whole getting a book published is a
lot easier than getting a feature film
funded shot and distributed this gives
authors a freedom to explore subject
matter tone and theme in a very granular
way books can be aimed at incredibly
narrow audiences and still be considered
successful these end up being the most
common sources of
a patient's sickness budget constraints
length constraints and market appeal but
before we get into the flaws we have to
mention something chapter two books
aren't perfect even though a book is the
way that it is does not make it a
perfect whole authors are still humans
still operating under limited time and
attention and mistakes digression z' and
flaws are all a part of the creative
process editing cutting stuff out is
just as important to making a book as
writing it down in the first place
there's always the possibility that
changes made in adaptation will serve a
vital editorial role resulting in an
overall better product the best example
of this that I can think of really is
lay miserab do you hear the people sing
singing the song of Angry Men it is the
music of a people who will not be slaves
again well I enjoy the book there is no
dodging around the fact that it was
written at a time when writers were paid
per page delivered leading to many many
long digression zin to historical
minutiae that served no purpose other
than to introduce a minor location for
events within the story and to bring
Victor Hugo a paycheck in the end the
stage musical cutting away a lot of the
fat and tweaking some of the core
characters and events does a far better
job at telling the story at the
emotional core of lame is than the book
does the books not bad but it's really
best read if you're looking for info
dumps about history not a moving story
the same process can apply to character
settings and subplots just as well as
the main story in Jurassic Park several
characters are changed for the better by
merging minor characters and shuffling
traits ages and actions around not
everything that works in a book works on
screen books and films have a different
pace a different rhythm they build
tension and communicate action in
different ways some things like politics
and minutia may read well but would bog
down a film books have the advantage
that they are not temporarily
synchronous experiences meaning that the
readers experience isn't locked to
anything else
you read the book at the pace that you
read the book when you sit down to watch
a movie you're in a synchronous
experience you start the movie and it
plays beginning to end page after page
of internal monologue or narrow
Oriol explanation might be fine for a
book but it can be really hard to
translate that to a film while keeping
things visually interesting or keeping
the movie short a 700 page book is a lot
more acceptable than a five-hour movie
on the other hand some books translated
to screen might become too short film as
an audiovisual medium can convey emotion
and tone quickly with the look on an
actor's face the framing of a shot the
color palette and the soundtrack
what might take pages to convey in a
book could take mere seconds on screen
lastly many a book can benefit from
broadening the audience appeal a lot of
books rely heavily on the reader having
knowledge of genre conventions or the
events in other related books and
smoothing things over can make the story
a bit more sane and tightly-knit
comic book movies are all a great
example of this to the point that I'm
starting to prefer the movie versions of
several characters more than any of
their actual comic versions in the end
not all changes are bad changes chapter
3 adaptation sickness like I already
said most of the changes are going to
stem from either budget constraints time
constraints or an appeal to the mass
market so these also become a big source
of problems any of the changes mentioned
trimming the plot altering characters
altering setting and so on can make for
a terrible adaptation if it sacrifices
something core to the original or fails
to bring in its own unique
interpretation I realize that sounds a
bit tautological that changes don't suck
unless they suck but it's not quite that
reductive I'm a big fan of the phrase
use dictates meaning when it comes to
words and it applies here too in this
context the way that readers use or
interpret a book dictates an essential
part of the books meaning if you want to
guess whether a change will negatively
impact the integrity of the adaptation
ask yourself what it is that readers
like about the book in the first place
Jurassic Park made a ton of changes to
just about everything on the list but
it's still a good adaptation because it
leaves that core appeal intact it's
still a suspenseful action story about a
group of normal people who get stuck in
a park filled with dinosaurs it still
brushes up against moral and ethical
questions of science and progress and it
still explores the wonder that dinosaurs
fill us with a film that suffers from
adaptation sickness is a film that has
missed the core appeal due to
constraints a lack of skill in the
adaptors apathy or by combination of the
same and now we can finally get around
to talking about the Earthsea cycle and
stuff
chapter 4 finally getting around to
talking about the Earthsea cycle and
stuff
alright let's change the pace and [ __ ]
about a crappy movie for a bit
the Earthsea books are about a wizard
named
his growth as a person how he influences
and reacts to the changes in the world
around him and the adventures he has
along the way there were also about a
woman named dinar who will get her own
section later the Earthsea miniseries is
about a wizard named ed who learns he's
a wizard goes to Hogwarts accidentally
unleashes a great evil stops an evil
warlord saves the world from destruction
and finds true love it's also about a
woman shaped mannequin named tanara
straight off the top this thing is a
piece of crap it's not just a bad
adaptation it's also poorly made it is
the cynics Holy Grail I don't really
need to go through it stage by stage
because it just doesn't matter it so
consistently lays you that I can just
hit the main technical parts and you can
imagine that for two straight hours it
rarely reaches anything hilariously bad
so I'd really only recommend actually
watching it for people who are really
curious or just completionists in
general the entire movie feels
completely inauthentic this does not
feel like a foreign place it looks fake
it sounds fake and it feels fake it's
not characters embroiled in events its
actors pretending to be characters who
are doing things because that's what was
written in the script scenes are shot
with the least imagination possible
framed in boring utilitarian ways and
using the fewest number of shots needed
to get coverage the whole thing is shot
at high frame rate and lit as uniformly
as possible ensuring that everything
looks as fake as possible oh and there's
an inexplicable fog filter over the
majority of the movie a few times that
the camerawork does show some innovation
it's sunk by terrible line readings of a
script that's well it sounds cliche to
say that it's insulting but did you see
those red markings on the side of a test
very attractive I've read about a dragon
once with markings like girls
pasady you tell me about the fire one
night waiting at red markings
the dragon the ravage devil that's the
one you remember it's true day one to
find it
I want to subdue it to you well you can
ask it any question you desire yes
oh boy I really crammed all those points
in there I want us to do it too well she
can ask it anything questions you desire
yes also the special effects look like
crap and the whole thing rings of
cheapness there is a scene near the
beginning where kargh ad Raiders attack
Goods village in the book yet defeats
them by summoning a thick fog creating
the illusion of ghosts and apparitions
in the fog scaring the superstitious
Raiders off in the movie huh oh man in
the movie he summons a fog and then the
villagers taunt the invaders and trick
them into running off a cliff Looney
Tunes style they don't even put much
effort into hiding the fact that there's
maybe at best a dozen invaders and the
fog is clearly the product of a couple
smoke machines the absolute best part of
that scene and by best I mean dumbest is
that at the end after all the soldiers
run off the cliff like morons there's
one more guy who tackles get off the
cliff like seven seconds after everyone
else has plunged to their doom
seriously this blows my mind
this guy was lagging behind the group by
a good 14 paces heard them all scream as
they ran off a cliff and decided to just
keep pushing forward into an obvious
trap well I guess we shouldn't give any
of the soldiers credit for intelligence
seeing as they kept chasing the
villagers even after get loud Lee
announced his plan to trap them it's
almost hilarious as far as how they
handled the adaptation they completely
fat-fingered it they mashed the first
two books together which really wasn't
needed at all but makes some sense some
sense terrible sense but some sense I'll
get back to that they keep the plot that
forms the backbone of the first book
we're dead accidentally releases a dark
spirit called a gibbet while trying to
summon the ghost of a dead heroine in a
magical pissing match and has to learn
how to defeat it before it takes over
his body and uses his wizard powers to
wreck the place props where props are
due this plot thread actually resembles
the book in an identifiable way and even
ends with the same reveal I know your
true name shadow but they also merge in
a whole element from the second book
with the ring that they changed to an
amulet in order to distance themselves
from the Lord of the Rings and instead
of it being a vaguely defined peace
offering they turn it into a magical
trump card that shoots light and
presumably erases all evil from the
planet it's no wonder that Ursula Kael
again called this Frankenstein's
Earthsea oh yeah Lagoon is still alive
she's old but she's still alive and
she's seen this movie I cannot imagine
sitting through this with her I'd die I
would wish death on myself and everyone
around me just to spare us all the
embarrassment
so what other changes did they make they
changed the race of the main character
from dark reddish brown skin to saltine
white they changed a lot of names they
added a world conquering warlord added a
bunch of his lackeys compressed the
timeline dramatically removed the themes
of identity and self-acceptance drop
several extended sequences discarded the
gender politics rebuilt metaphysical
morality of the world cultures into a
science versus religion pseudo metaphor
and made so many changes to the second
book that I'm going to give that its own
section later when I talk about tener
basically the majority of the second
half was made up for the miniseries and
only occasionally picks out elements
from the books to contextualize these
changes we have to be honest about the
original books the adaptation
necessities first yes there are sections
of the books that could be dropped for
brevity there are several detours in the
first book that are interesting but are
either distractions or set up elements
that aren't paid off until subsequent
books second well this isn't so much a
necessity as it is a specific challenge
and that's maintaining the tone of the
books the books are extremely
introspective and prose heavy focusing
mostly on the spiritual evolution of its
characters there are self-actualization
their reactions to the world around them
this is challenging to adapt because a
lot of that needs to be woven into the
dialogue or crafted with camerawork
editing and music while at the same time
trying to keep the overall pace up so
that you still hit the points where get
defeats the invaders summons the dark
thing faces off against the dragons
fights the getteth and eventually chases
it across the ocean to confront it these
are some things to keep in mind but
they're hardly insurmountable in a
screenplay and can be done while holding
on to the core appeal in my mind the
core appeals of the books are the
culture and themes the world of Earthsea
is extremely well realized the
characters and cultures are diverse
complex and feel authentic the decisions
that the characters make are informed by
the cultures that they come from and
have significance because the character
is either accepting or rejecting the
expectations of their culture they are
surprised and often confused or
fascinated by the customs and
expectations of others this culture also
informs the running theme of identity
the main character of the books well
he's the main character of the first and
third book but he's also really
important in the second and fourth and
has a minor role in the fifth the
central character of the books is get
also known as Sparrowhawk Donnie Hawke
and Caleb see he's got five names and
each of them has its own significance
and speaks to both the cultures that led
to giving of the names as well as the
evolution of the character throughout
his life a lot of the time in the books
is spent talking about names the
importance of names the
names that people choose for themselves
the names that people are given by
others and how naming practices differ
among different groups a lot of that
probably sounds pretty boring but it's
not or it doesn't have to be it's only
boring and confusing because I'm trying
to explain it in the worst forum
possible by telling and not showing the
best way to handle it is actually by
under explaining it a lot of the times
when it comes to complicated stories
particularly science fiction or fantasy
worlds we end up talking about audience
surrogates someone that everyone else
needs to explain crap to so that the
audience knows what's going on the key
to doing it well is to have people
explain the important stuff but also
leave a lot of unimportant stuff
unexplained even a surrogate character
should already know something about the
world they live in this is where ligands
work shines and is largely where
adapting for screen becomes the most
challenging the Earth's ebooks do a
masterful job at building a rich world
with deeply realized cultures all while
walking the fine line of explanation
communicating the details without
blatant info dumps in the world of
Earthsea a person's true name is
something very important knowing
someone's true name is a sign of utmost
trust and learning your own true name as
a rite of passage into adulthood that
everyone goes through the books lay this
out slowly
it's so deep rooted into the culture
that everyone just knows about it and
you get the sense of how important it is
from the respect that everyone gives it
the movie treats it like the password to
a clubhouse but I can't help you if you
don't tell me who you really are
spero I'll take your letter to the arch
Magus I said earlier that they didn't
need to match the first two books
together and I stand by that the first
books plot is actually quite
conventional despite the introspective
tone dead learns he's special at a young
age is raised by a mentor has a run-in
with power he can't control is sent out
into the larger world studies magic
bites off more than he can chew is
humbled hides from his destiny slowly
regains his confidence and eventually
overcomes his literal and metaphorical
demons in the climax
it's the hero's journey to a tee get
spiritual journey is mirrored by his
physical journey as he adventures from
place to place as
travels he earns new names a further
metaphor on his evolving personal
identity meets new people and learns new
lessons there's not really much reason
to merge the first and second books
together especially since the second
book takes place almost entirely in a
single location and is focused on a very
internal struggle but I understand why
they made that decision I don't agree
with it but I understand it they needed
a love interest chapter 5:10 are now
let's talk about tanara this right here
has to be the greatest betrayal of the
books and is a sadly common evil to be
inflicted on adaptations in general I'd
say it fits under audience appeal but
really I'd put it under hedging the bet
they turned to NAR into a doe-eyed naive
priestess love interest rescue victim
who teaches get to follow his heart or
some pointless book like that she's all
good and pure and perfect and the evil
people conspire against her and she gets
locked up and gets saves her and they
fall in love and they save the world
because their love is just so pure and
perfect and seriously screw this change
just hold it down and smash its toes
with a ball-peen hammer the writers
deserve to suffer for this one who is
ten are ten are also known as are ha is
the principal character of the second
and fourth books in the series even
though she's the protagonist when we
first meet her in tombs of Aswan she is
not the good guy
she is the nascent High Priestess of
Otto on a cult of women and eunuchs that
serve and protect the nameless powers of
the earth in their lightless death trap
tombs out in the desert the order steals
her from her mother shortly after her
birth and they take away her name the
new name they give her are ha means the
Eden one
she is offered as a living sacrifice to
Dark Gods Dan get up read from the book
oh let the nameless ones behold the girl
given to them who is verily the one born
every nameless let them accept her life
in the years of her life until her death
which is
also there's let them find her
acceptable
let her be eaten other voices shrill and
harshest trumpets replied she is eaten
she is
eaten that is tanara the one Priestess
of the tombs of awe on highest of all
High Priestesses of the car gad lands
one whom not even the god king himself
might command that is ten are not this
I'm so pleased for you I remember when
you first came here I lost frightened
little orphan full of questions you're a
charming little waif first in for
understanding wasn't she venerable
mother something horrible happened here
tonight something beyond anything I've
known
ah we have faith briefing
I brought my soul back from the break
can a fetch a spare does not yet left
his body immediately sorry about this
this makes me actually angry here in the
movie she's demure pure virginal and
completely boring The Sisterhood has
changed from being the servants of the
dark powers into being the gatekeepers
of their prison the tombs are reduced to
a set piece that they name drop as if to
let you know hey see this is totally
from the book - nor is turned from
active agent into victim
she's framed for murder and does little
more than pout in the books tener grows
up in the darkness revered as the chosen
one of their dark masters she has three
men put to death by starvation she
tortures them by letting their torch
burn out so they are left to die in
pitch black she has the bodies buried in
the center place of their dark powers
where she says her masters will eat
their bodies she meets get in the tombs
where he's trespassing hunting for an
artifact and traps him she spends a good
chunk of the book trying to decide
exactly how to have him put to death for
blasphemy this aspect of tener her
fanaticism in her role as High Priestess
is central to her character arc Dead
challenges her identity as the Eden one
and suggests that she is not our hot the
priestess defaults gods but tanara
the little girl who was stolen from her
mother 10 our struggle is a crisis of
faith and a crisis of identity and the
way that she reacts to that crisis the
way that she integrates them into
herself are what makes her amazing
character where a wizard of Earthsea
uses a world-spanning journey as the
metaphor forgets evolution the tombs of
aswan uses a maze full of hidden
treasures world-changing secrets and
even darkness as a metaphor for to nars
evolution dead brings light to our house
maze and from that she learns things
about herself that she never knew what
they did was strip all of that out and
throw it away purely to insert a love
interest into the story
epilogue there's one big change that I
haven't dwelt on all that
but they invented a new character ty
gasps a warlord bent on world domination
I haven't said much about him because
there's there's not much to say I mean
world domination there you can already
guess everything he says and does
presumably they added him in order to up
the ante to raise the stakes
but he's pointless there's no need for
him he'll even within the mangled story
of the miniseries he's redundant with
the giveth the crappy effects I can
forgive the cheap cinematography the
lack of extras the lame acting the fake
looks I can forgive the script I can't
forgive its unending badness shows off a
ham-handed disregard for the source
material a casual and blatant
exploitation of the books purely for a
tiny bit of brand-name recognition this
is just about the absolute worst an
adaptation can get as it shows zero
respect for either the source material
or the audience it's not a script caught
between a rock and a hard place it's a
script mangled by filmmakers who just
didn't care
bottom line miniseries no books yes